some people thought that I was a skeptic  that's actually not true I I'm asking  detailed questions because I want to  know what was the error like on this  alien ship I want to know what did the  glass rod feel like was it heavy was  Gravity the same and so on I'm curious  to know about Skinwalker what's going on  at Skinwalker and what's its connections  to  what's his connection to UFOs when you  go looking  for the phenomenon uh it basically  doesn't show itself fascinating with  Skinwalker is that um you basically have  the convergence of multiple you know  things happening and their cattle are  missing or cattle mutilation where blood  is gone a lot of like really weird  things about it like maybe the cuts are  in between cells maybe there's no  vascular collapse maybe it happened  within 10 minutes I mean lights in the  sky Poltergeist events were all  happening there